blind arise asks all of this recent  disclosure and activity has been very  u.s focused  it would be interesting to know if other  countries are working on this stuff too  or are cooperating at some level the  implication is that  whoever can reverse engineer this tech  first wins but isn't our chance  isn't it best to give our chance to all  humans  yes yes yes and yes yes on all four  parts yes uh uh  you know there are other countries  working on this yes there are other  governments that are reaching out to  work with us  uh yes that uh he who who  who reveals the secret first has the  advantage and yes this would be better  for humanity if we worked it all  together